the dave chappelle like
it's just gonna actually yeah there are
a lot of people i feel like we
what where we are right now you see
something on twitter you'll see a
headline and you read the comments below
and that's about the amount of
information that you get like people are
not researching people are not doing
stuff the people who i saw talking [ __ ]
about the dave chappelle special clearly
did not watch it
because
because i went and i watched it my
roommate is a trans girl we sat and
watched together were there a couple
jokes that were definitely a little like
oh
yeah but the majority of it was [ __ ]
hilarious and at the end of it too he
says multiple times like i am not here
to [ __ ] on trans people like
so you all don't need to be attacking me
yeah and that's just real like i think
we are very sensitive and
i mean not all the time i don't want to
seem like i'm blanking everyone but
yeah i think it's
and i think that also comes from where i
grew up like i can see where people have
have good intentions yeah yeah so
regardless of if dave chappelle people
were going off i'm like oh he's not
telling the truth he's lying is it it
doesn't matter he's a comedian
you're gonna and it's it's a [ __ ]
stand-up special like
yeah and i again i think it's so
ridiculous to take things out of context
and then to because even too like i
could see how that the one clip from the
ig video if you just watched that clip
and you did not watch the other 40
minutes that he was talking about my
penis then
you would you know like you wouldn't get
all of the love and admiration
[Laughter]
she's talking about what i said
but no i think that's an interesting i
think this interesting response is also
like like people talk about a lot about
like a like a privilege or whatever like
a white privilege and i think like
like i think
white privilege is uh one facet of it is
being able to have like your own unique
thoughts
like because i don't have to
represent the group right so like
you represent you have to represent the
group if you're not the group is going
to be upset at you yeah but the group
also is under attack so it's like yo
guys even if we don't all agree exactly
let's kind of band together do this
black people have to do this i'm sure
you guys have that [ __ ] pressure even
you saying the stuff you said today
you're like man i dealt with so much
[ __ ] scrutiny well i know that there
are people who are just not gonna [ __ ]
with me after this [ __ ] comes out yeah
just straight up you feel me a nice like
i make music like i'm a rapper and [ __ ]
i know that there are [ __ ] who aren't
going to work with me who are going to
call me all types of names and it just
is what the [ __ ] it is
because you're deciding to be your
unique self yeah and that's what
just like you said it's like there is no
there's no monolith there's no group and
that's that's what freed me like when i
was younger i felt like oh all black
people like my skin folk or my kim folk
and i love black people right but it's
like
just because he's black he doesn't have
the best
um intentions for me it's like it's
about character about how people are
treating you and just like i'm just me
i'm just here being me i'm doing me
if you don't want to date a trans person
you don't have to just shut the [ __ ] up
yeah
like yeah like it's really this [ __ ] is
simple it's like we just need to mind
our own [ __ ] business yeah and you're
and i and i get i get i get both sides
like i get the the trans community when
they're like yo we need to band together
because we got to fight this fight but i
also get the individual trans person
who's like
i kind of think this is funny even
though it's about me and so i understand
i i i have empathy for the internal
struggle and i have empathy for the
person who goes man i don't necessarily
want to be an activist even though i
know it's important i got to support
these people i also just want to be
daisy yeah i also just want to be jayden
or also just want to be derek or
whatever and that's a [ __ ]
that is a difficult that's a difficult
thing yeah i mean i think we're all the
butt of the joke at some point well
like literally like yes that's that's
the whole point of comedy um
you can't laugh at someone else if you
not want to laugh at yourself no that's
that's real so i just yeah i
i hate
i hate i just everyone's fighting i
don't want to fight everyone's fighting
every group is fighting with each other
i don't want to [ __ ] fight like yeah
we can just have fun and again yeah it's
things are funny and everything's not
that serious
uh yeah i feel like i just see a lot of
[ __ ] where
understandably especially with trans
women like we wanna be safe and stuff
girl you are not gonna die every single
time that you you know like you are not
fighting for your safety every time
maybe you know maybe that's wrong with
me to say maybe maybe some people are if
you live in gotham
yeah but it's
yeah
no
i feel like we should just be having
more fun i think
well everything that's my hope always
with with with this podcast is that like
you know we have tons of different
people coming here we all have fun and
the commonality is we like busting balls
and making jokes yeah and uh
that's that's yeah that's kind of our
goal i don't like to state our goals
like that because i don't want to be too
uh preachy about it but if that can kind
of come across and we can create an
environment where people have fun i
think that we can
do a lot more good than harm